Suplementar antioxidantes diminui a
produção endógena? Uma pergunta muito
inteligente, muito interessante e muito
polêmica também. A questão dos
antioxidantes e a sua interferência na
produção endógena tem que ter uma
análise individualizada. Temos que
considerar o estado inflamatório de cada
paciente. Tem gente que não é
necessariamente um bom candidato por
antioxidação. Existe um conceito chamado
dormese, que eu acho um conceito muito
interessante, muito importante. Ele
segue o princípio popular do que não
mata engorda, ou do que não mata
fortalece. Então, pequenos insultos,
pequenos estresses oxidativos podem
estimular nossas defesas naturais e
tornar o nosso organismo mais forte,
mais existente. É o caso, por exemplo,
do vento batendo nas árvores e
fortalecendo
as mesmas, né? Então, desafios leves a
moderados ativam genes antioxidantes e
anti-inflamatórios e promove adaptações
benéficas. Porém, essa lógica, ela só se
aplica a pessoas saudáveis, OK?
Para uma pessoa saudável, ormésia é bom.
Para uma pessoa doente pode não ser bom.
Então, indivíduos com inflamação crônica
elevada, o caso de artriteide, artrite
crônica, diabetes, obesidade, doenças
cardiovasculares, o organismo já tá
sobrecarregado de base. Então, nesses
casos, os sistemas antioxidantes da
pessoa, os endógenos, estão exauridos,
estão incapazes de neutralizar o excesso
de radicais livres que vão perpetuar o
dano celular.
Então, para esses pacientes altamente
inflamados, a suplementação,
pelo ponto de vista ortomolecular, não
representa uma interferência prejudicial
em si, mas é um suporte terapêutico
essencial.
Seria a mesma coisa de você dar muletas
para quem não tá conseguindo andar
direito, que não faria sentido você
entregar essa muleta para uma pessoa que
está normal. Então, a medicina
ortomolecular demonstra que quando o
estresse oxidativo supera drasticamente
a capacidade de defesa natural, a
intervenção com antioxidantes em doses
terapêuticas, tá, torna-se então
necessária para restaurar esse
equilíbrio. Então, é muito importante, é
fundamental nós distinguirmos entre
antioxidantes sintéticos e os naturais.
Os estudos que demonstraram efeitos
negativos, tem estudos aí largamente
divulgados, falando mal da vitamina A e
da vitamina E, né, incluindo o aumento
de mortalidade, utilizaram as formas
sintéticas da vitamina A, que é o
retinol, e a forma sintética da vitamina
E, que é o DL, alfa tocoferol.
Então, essas formas isoladas e
artificiais, elas não reproduzem a
natureza real, a complexidade dos
antioxidantes naturais, que contém
vários isômeros, né, várias formas
diferentes e cofatores cinégésicos que
vão ajudando um ao outro, né, como se
fosse um efeito comitiva. Então, a
vitamina E natural, ela é composta por
oito diferentes tocoferidis e
tocotrenoid que quando atua em conjunto,
enquanto a versão sintética apresenta
apenas uma fração dessa atividade
biológica. Então, da mesma maneira, os
carotenóides naturais formam complexo,
né, uma turma que age em conjunto, que
trabalha de forma sinégica, que é
diferente do betacaroteno sintético
isolado. Então, a prática clínica
ortomolecular,
ela privilegia antioxidantes em suas
formas naturais e complexos nutricionais
completos.
Isso vai ter mais segurança, vai imitar
de maneira mais eficiente a natureza,
vai ter eficácia maior. Então, pacientes
com marcadores elevados de inflamação
crônica de fato se beneficiam de forma
significativa dessa suplementação
individualizada e apresentam redução de
sintomas e melhora dos parâmetros
bioquímicos. Então, cada caso é um caso.
Pessoas saudáveis podem não precisar,
pessoas cronicamente inflamáveis
certamente vão precisar. Ok? Então, o
que que eu recomendo? Pessoas saudáveis,
baixo grau de inflamatório, vamos focar
nos estímulos horméticos naturais.
Exercício, exposição controlada a
temperaturas, né? Você pode fazer aquela
técnica de sauna e banho gelado,
consumo de fitoquímicos através dos
alimentos, né? os vegetais coloridos,
cada um deles tem um polifenol
diferente. Então, nesses casos,
suplementação pode ser desnecessária,
simir
na adaptação benéfica, na hormese.
Então, a avaliação bioquímica individual
é fundamental. Nós temos que usar os
marcadores de estresse oxidativo, de
perfil inflamatório para poder
determinar quem precisa suplementar e
quem não precisaria ou não se
beneficiaria desses
suplementos e deveria utilizar apenas
estímulos horméticos. Compartilhe os
vídeos, faça bem. A vida de alguém pode
mudar também no canal do Dr. Além do se
envolva. Ah.